And now it's the old scout master.
So one of my scouts told me that it was difficult for my generation to understand his world.
You were up in a different world. he said. you know, there's there's more computing
power in my cell phone than the biggest computer in the world had when you were my age.
We have the internet and ways to communicate you could only dream of.
I looked at him and I said: you know, you're right,
We didn't have them and we did dream of them,
And then we invented them for you and you're welcome.
Oh well, hey, this is podcast number 141..
So welcome back to the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green and this message comes from Bruce Mueller, who is assistant
scout master of troop 209 and Northwest Suburban Council,
And he wrote in to say: Clark, I just wanted to drop you a line of thanks.
Your words frequently speak to me in the needs of our scouts.
They're often shared among leaders of our troop and council, often affirming
what we know, occasionally challenged what we think, but they're always appreciated.
Keep up the good work.
If you're ever in the Chicagoland area, we would be delighted to share a
campfire with you anytime and show our thanks.
Well, thanks so much, Bruce,
Thanks for your kind words-
They always mean a lot- and thanks for being in touch.
Over on Google plus, Robert Slike shared this.
He said we had a fantastic troop meeting the other night.
My boys followed the instructions put out by scoutmastercgcom on how to set up patrols.
We had leadership elections and I have a new cadre of youth leaders
from the top on down and I'm looking forward to it.
And Robert is a scout master for a troop down in Fort Bragg.
Thanks so much, Robert, and I'm glad you were able to put it to work for your troop.
Heard from Mike, who's an assistant scout master of troop 1434 in Potomac, Maryland.
He said I promoted your website and Frank
Marinard's blog, Bob White Blather and the Brian on scouting blog and ask Andy
column on the net commission during my second week of wood badge training.
I remain surprised by how committed scouts are thrilled to learn
of these great resources since they haven't yet come across them.
Well, those are some key things
I'll tell you. Frank Marinards blog, Bob White Blather, is written
from the standpoint of Frank being a committee chair.
He's got excellent information on there, something that you definitely want to check out.
Brian on scouting: that's the official blog, I believe of scouting magazine right
And always good, up to date information on what's going on with Boy Scouts
from America and ask Andy. if you haven't found, ask Andy.
Well, you must rush right over there
And he's on the US scouting service project.
They are really good resources and, Mike, I am honored to be counted amongst them.
Thank you very much. Another Mike, Michael Gros of Crestline,
California, wrote in to say this: I have recently discovered your podcast.
I'm currently going through the archives and have enjoyed the information
and the relaxed, friendly format.
I'm volunteering at Forest Lawn Scout Reservation.
I'd like to get permission to broadcast your podcast on our camp radio station.
Well, of course you can, Mike, use this podcast and all the other information
you find at ScoutmasterCGcom freely.
If it can help, if it can support scouting in any way, you go on ahead and use it.
And if you go down to the bottom of the page
on any page at ScoutmasterCGcom, you'll see the little Creative Commons license thing.
It doesn't have many things in the way of restriction and sharing,
It's just. I guess what it's called is a attribution no alteration kind of thing
Where so long as you attribute the work to me and so long as you don't alter it.
share it all you want. That's fine.
And good friend of the blog and the podcast, Bill Daniel,
Scoutmaster from Troop 132, responded to a post that I put out recently.
He says: thank you for your service to scouting.
You've posted about a divisive subject and naturally we're not going to solve it
over the blog. And Bill goes on to ask this interesting question.
He says: should we avoid it in this community of scouts that you and other
contributors have created, or be divided or be distracted?
This blog and podcast has the effect of approving the hands-on impact
of scouts in scouts lives. every week
Its circle of influence is expanding.
Troops are improving.
Scouts are growing in their ability to help scouts develop through the methods
of the program. I encourage you to stay the course,
unify and keep encouraging adults to trust the program because it works
Well. Bill, I really do appreciate that.
Now I am going to uncharacteristically and just for a moment,
go into this area of debatable questions for a moment.
A lot of us have been talking and have been distracted and potentially
divided by the news in recent weeks.
These are kind of divisive times.
We're in the midst of a hotly contested presidential election.
The Boy Scouts of America is working through some major controversies
over past practices and reporting child abuse and in challenges
to excluding gay leaders and now, apparently, scouts,
And this is getting a lot of airtime.
These are touchy issues to talk about, but I want to offer my
thoughts because I think the airways are full of stories
And I know that a lot of us are feeling unsettled- and I mean us.
It's unsettling.
I don't know that it's a good idea for me to pass judgment on
or discuss the BSA's membership policies, because as soon as we open
that door, that's all we're going to be talking about
And there are going to be points about which good people can disagree,
just like politics and just like religion.
OK, And that's why we don't discuss them in detail here,
because they distract us from serving our scouts.
For a moment, let's lay all those things aside
and think about scouting beyond the context of organizations
and personalities and see it as its founder did,
because Baden Powell and vision. scouting is a vehicle for bringing peace to the world.
because of this vision, over the last century,
Scouting has found a home in many, many places in the world.
We reverence and respect different expressions of religions,
politics, nationality and culture and, beyond simply tolerating those differences,
We accept that they're our strength.
We accept that diversity is important.
You know, last summer, high in the Bernie's Alps, in Condorsteg, Switzerland,
I had the great pleasure of sitting around a campfire with our fellow scouts
from Portugal and we had a wonderful evening. just you know, being scouts,
We shared some kitchen space and an eating area with scouts from Great Britain.
We spent time with scouts from Switzerland, of course,
in Brazil and Mauritius and Russia and Kenya and Greece and many other places,
And we couldn't all speak the same language,
We didn't all worship the same God,
We didn't share the same political opinions, but we came together,
having a whole lot in common, just because we were scouts,
And that's the heart of the movement.
So our scouting movement is bigger than political or religious or moral dogma.
Scouting is a simple expression of values common to every enlightened
society throughout human history.
These values aren't anything new.
They're too broad to be owned by any one religious or political
or organizational point of view.
Each scout judges their own heart.
We look on our fellow scouts as we hope they look on us
with understanding and acceptance and tolerance.
The genius of scouting is that we look beyond differences
to what we hold in common.
Now, division is easy,
Division is cheap and division is cowardly.
And when people try to divide us on matters of politics,
on matters of religion, on matters of custom and culture,
it's an easy job.
Unity is what takes a lot of work.
Unity requires us to accommodate charitably those with whom we disagree.
It requires us to bravely share our world and ourselves
with those who disagree with us.
Organizations and religions and political parties. they're pretty inflexible,
They're slow to change, but they do eventually.
They're bound by rules and policies and traditions.
They're inherently intolerant and insular.
They're kind of tribal
And these sound like bad things.
But all I'm doing is this is just observational.
OK, don't see this as a negative judgment about the nature of organizations.
I'm just observing that this is generally true.
Maybe the next great leap of humanity will come when we finally do away
with all the pettiness and divisions of tribalism
and embrace the common good in each other.
And I'll bet scouting will have a big part in that.
What did our founder say?
What did the guy who put all this together have to tell us?
Well, Beaton Powell, in his last message to scout leaders, said:
our aim is to produce healthy, happy, helpful citizens,
to eradicate the prevailing narrow self interest:
personal, political, sectarian and national,
and to substitute for it a broader spirit of self sacrifice
and service in the cause of humanity,
and thus to develop mutual goodwill and cooperation,
not only within our own country but abroad, between all countries.
Experience shows that this consummation is no idle or fantastic dream,
but is a practical possibility if we work for it.
Therefore, you, you scout leaders, are not only doing a great work
for your neighbor's children, but you're also helping in a practical
fashion to bring to pass God's kingdom of peace and goodwill on earth.
So, from my heart, I wish you Godspeed in your effort.
I definitely couldn't say it any better than Beaton Powell.
I hope that helps you, in these potentially divisive times,
to think a little bit broader and hopefully, to address
whatever concerns you may have and to unite us
around the common things that we hold.
We're going to have differences of politics,
We're going to have differences of religion,
We're going to have differences of custom and culture,
But we can unite around scouting, can't we?
So the remainder of this podcast we're going to spend answering
a lot of email questions.
I counted three or four or five, I guess, and they look like
important questions that, I think, will help everybody out.
So let's get started. shall we
Write me a letter, send it my name
Email? that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails,
The first email question. I'm going to withhold the names
and the identifying characteristics
And you'll see why. I have a situation where my son is essentially
being pushed out of scouts by his scout master.
He is 15 and plays club soccer and high school soccer.
He's currently a star scout and he is not being allowed to advance
the life because he cannot fulfill his position of responsibility
for six months straight.
His scout master will only let him fulfill this position
of responsibility by being a patrol leader when there are
many other positions available
And there's also the option for a special project.
But the scout master is reading the position of responsibility
as leadership.
My son is basically in the position of choosing soccer or scouts,
but he isn't welcome to do both.
When you have scout masters who are unwilling to work with the
scouts that have other interests besides scouting,
that's when you lose a scout too.
That's an upsetting message, isn't it?
There are several issues that it suggests that.
Let's see if we can unravel some of this
In the star life and eagle requirements.
you see the words position of responsibility
a term for an office, whether elected or appointed,
that a boy holds to qualify for those ranks.
The words position of responsibility are carefully chosen
because not every boy is a leader
and not every boy will become a leader. quote unquote.
Every scout, by taking out a position of responsibility,
is certainly going to use some leadership skills
and is certainly going to develop some leadership skills,
But, quite wisely to my mind, we have divorced
the term leadership from position of responsibility,
because too many people use it to discourage-
as is in the case of the person who sent me this email-
rather than encourage scouts.
So if we look at it from the standpoint of a position
of responsibility and fulfilling those responsibilities,
the intention of the requirement becomes much clearer, doesn't it?
So remember, when evaluating whether or not
a scout has fulfilled a position of responsibility,
it's not whether or not he has fulfilled a leadership position,
even though we use the terms interchangeably a lot.
just, you know, as we hack around and we do scouting.
But remember that that's what the requirement says:
position of responsibility. OK,
One of the other things we can kind of unravel here
is this particular scout master's objection
that the boy is not serving in a continuous fashion for six months.
Well, if you go to the Guide to Advancement 2011,,
you will find continuous service may not be required
by the unit to qualify for a rank.
If a boy is active for three months and then he's away for two,
and then he's active for another two, and he's away for one,
and he's active for another month in and then he's away for one,
He's got his six months.
So service in a position of responsibility
does not have to be continuous.
Then let's talk about active. OK,
Because this scout master- and I didn't read you the entire email,
I kind of edited it a little bit-
But this scout master is also concerned
that the scout is not fulfilling the active requirement
because he hasn't been to the troop standard.
They've said a numerical standard of something like 75 percent
of the meetings and 50 percent of the outings or something like that,
And so he hasn't met that metric standard
and the scout master considers that that's the end of the story.
as far as active goes,
Again, go to the Guide to Advancement,
Go to section four.
Take a look at how active is determined,
because there's a very easy three step process.
We've discussed this before.
So step number one is he's registered.
That's easy,
That's just an administrative thing.
He's a registered scout,
That's all we need.
Step number two: he's in good standing.
and it's going to be extraordinarily rare
that a scout is not in good standing
because what that means is he's not been dismissed
for disciplinary reasons or, for one way
or one way or another, excluded from membership
by the local council.
And step number three is that if the troop establishes
a metric standard- and yes, that's allowed,
I wouldn't do it in a million years if it was me- OK,
but some troops find that useful-
If he meets the troops metric standard
of whatever they decide- 75 percent or 50 percent
or something like that- then he meets the requirements.
If he doesn't meet that standard, though,
he must, MUST, must be allowed to be evaluated
under an alternative method that considers
the activities outside his unit and outside of scouting.
That's a policy statement
and there's no getting away from it.
So if you're a troop, you've established
a metric standard about being active
and a scout doesn't meet that,
then the next thing that you do is you talk with the scout
and you ask him what he's doing outside of scouting.
that's kept him away.
The thing that scouting wants to do
is not totally monopolize a boy's time
so they can't be involved in anything else
and make him pay attention
only to what he's doing in scouting.
We want him to be an active member of his community.
We want him to be an active member of his school
and his family and his religious institution.
I mean, come on, that's what we want.
So scouting does not begin and end
at the threshold of the troop meeting room
or the gateway to the campsite.
It's in the community
And these are not things that
well, we'll just consider this
because we don't want to make the boy upset or anything.
No, this is real achievement.
He is out there living the scout oath and law
and expressing that in the things
that he is doing in the community,
And so we consider that
It's fair.
It's what we do for scouts.
For the 30-some years that I've been around scouting,
I get tired of people carrying on about older scouts
and how we have to do all this crazy stuff
to keep older scouts around.
We have to have these special programs
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
and somebody coined the whole fumes thing
years and years ago.
And if you haven't heard that
when a scout turns 15 or 16,
you lose them to the fumes, perfumes and car fumes
and whatever I don't know.
I've never liked that
because it's simply not true.
if you present the scout program,
So if he has real responsibilities leading his troop
and he is engaged and involved in that,
he's gonna stay interested.
And the other thing is
is that you can't build a fence around him
and say all you do is what you do with your troop.
He's going to do sports,
He's going to be in six different clubs after school.
He's going to be in his church youth group.
We see those not as being competing with scouting.
Actually, we see it as an expression
of the scout oath and law at work in a young man's life.
Here's a 15-year-old boy
who's out actively playing soccer
and he's really interested in that, okay.
And like 15-year-old boys,
they get on a tear about soccer or football or basketball.
It's the most important thing in the world to them.
That may last for a month or a couple of years,
or it may last for a lifetime
and more power to them.
That's great.
So what do you want?
Do you want scouting to be all or nothing for those boys,
Or do you want scouting to be a part of their lives?
When we present the program properly,
when we administer the advancement program properly.
we are letting scouting be a part of their lives. okay,
And that's the most important point.
I also had this email from Ann Olson
up in Plymouth, Minnesota,
and I mispronounced Plymouth very intentionally there.
So you can email me again
and tell me how to properly pronounce it
Inside. joke there, folks,
you gotta go back a couple of podcasts,
pick that one up.
But Ann asked:
I'm working as a unit commissioner for a pack and troop
that rarely uses den chiefs.
I think the stumbling block is the training requirement
which the scout master believes
he has to conduct himself at some point
in his busy schedule.
I found a 45-minute online training module,
but is there any more to it than that?
Well, Ann, I did a little looking around.
I don't think there's a training requirement for den chiefs
unless a scout's working as a den chief
and he wants to get a den chief award.
So I don't know whether I would call it a requirement.
I think training would be useful for them.
I don't know if they need a 45-minute online training
or if they just need a little bit of an introduction
and working together with the den leader
and maybe facilitating that.
But in your position as a commissioner,
I'd recommend you get all of those resources together,
share them with the troop and the pack
and maybe you offer to facilitate
whatever training orientation is needed.
The scout master-
there's no rule that says he has to conduct the training.
He may feel like he's the only one
who can conduct the training,
But if that's all then in his way
I think he ought to reconsider it.
Den chiefs are a great thing.
It can take some real effort to establish them
and establish a relationship with a cub pack,
But having den chiefs, especially in Weebelow's dens,
is a pretty important thing
for maintaining a good relationship
between packs and troops.
Dave wrote in and he said:
I'm looking for some documentation
that answers the question of whether or not
we can take a Weebelow's patrol camping with our troop
without their parents.
I am hoping that you can point me to that document.
The idea of this overnight
it was to provide the Weebelows
a first opportunity to camp without their parents
but still with familiar peers and adults.
I have always understood that Weebelow's patrols
can camp using troop rules.
The funny thing is
is that all these boys are bridging into troops in December.
It's not like something crazy will change in them
or me in the next two months
when there won't be any rules in our way
about them camping with the troop.
Dave, thanks for getting in touch
and thanks for asking the question.
I went to the guide to safe scouting,
which is easy to find online-
Guide to safe scouting, Google search.
take your right to it.
And there are age guidelines for camping. okay,
And I'm gonna read two of them to you.
One is overnight camping by Tiger, Cub Wolf
and Bear Cub Scout Dens. as dens is not approved,
That's an easy statement to understand.
Not approved, can't do it as a den.
The reason that I read that
will be clear in just a moment.
So what about Weebelow's dens?
Well, this is what the guide says:
A Weebelow Scout may participate
in overnight den camping when supervised by an adult.
In most cases, the Weebelow Scout
will be under the supervision
of his parent or guardian. in most cases,
It's essential that each Weebelow Scout
be under the supervision of a parent-approved adult.
Joint Weebelow's den troop campouts,
including the parents of the Weebelow Scouts,
are encouraged to strengthen ties
between the pack and the troop.
Den leaders, pack leaders and parents
are expected to accompany the boys on approved trips.
So question number one: can Weebelow's
go camping as a den?
Yes,
What kind of things need to happen there?
while they need to be under the supervision
of a parent or guardian and their leaders
or a parent-approved adult, right,
Can Weebelow's dens go on troop campouts?
Joint Weebelow's, den and troop campouts are encouraged
and it does especially note
including the parents of Weebelow's.
It says den leaders, pack leaders and parents
are expected to accompany the boys on approved trips.
That statement's kind of fuzzy.
Give some qualifications there
and it doesn't do it in a really clear way,
at least to my mind. all right,
On one hand it says in most cases-
and that would lead me to believe-
that parents do not have to accompany Weebelow's,
but then when it talks about joint campouts
with a den and a troop,
that it kind of indicates the parents
are expected to accompany the boys on approved trips.
So the conditions that I would wanna see
after reading this is that all the Weebelow's
will be accompanied by a parent-approved adult
and that could be a den or a pack leader.
You know, every once in a while
we run up against these kind of fuzzy areas
and we need to use our common sense.
Why would we have any special considerations
at all around Weebelow's camping?
Well, at their age we want them to have access
to familiar adults who know the boys.
We want parents, den leaders
or pack leaders will fill that bill.
And why do we want cub leaders
to have any kind of special training, like blue,
before they go camping?
So that they concentrate on the particular needs
of the boys of that age
and conduct age-appropriate activities? okay,
So that's the reason that those things are in place.
And while a scout master's training may apply
to a scouting, we're not maybe familiar
with what's appropriate for younger boys
in a Weebelow's den. okay,
And that year or two
between when they first joined Weebelow's
and they become Boy Scouts, it's a very big difference.
Even a couple of months is a big difference at that age
And it is more than likely that something crazy
will change in them in the next two months.
They'll be two months older,
And that's actually a pretty big deal
when you're 10 or 11 years old.
These rules around all this-
they may be a little fuzzy
and they may be difficult to find at times,
but they're working because they lead us
to think about what we're doing a little bit more
and understanding the reasons
that the rules are there in the first place
and then applying the concepts behind them,
And I would also note that the tour plan process
is pretty good at making sure
that we have the right kind of training prerequisites
for the activities that we're planning.
So if it passes muster there,
I think that's a pretty good indication
that you're good to go.
You know there are a lot more rules
and regulations out there now
than there were 30 years ago
when I first became an adult volunteer right,
And whenever I look at them you know what.
They seem to be pretty intelligent
and they help us avoid putting scouts in harm's way
and they focus us on the most effective parts of the program.
So this question comes from Michael Kerry,
who's the committee chair of Troop 167
in Charlotte, North Carolina,
And Michael emails me and says:
Clark, I enjoy your podcast.
Well, thank you, Michael.
Always nice to hear that.
Do any of your past podcasts
discuss new scout patrols and their pros and cons?
We currently don't have one,
but the idea is being talked about
and I'm looking for others past experiences.
Thanks for your time.
Well, thanks for being in touch, Mike.
That's a great question.
It's one that's been discussed in general,
but I don't think really specifically on the podcast.
So to answer it,
we've really got to think about some basics about patrols.
One of the most elemental things about scouting
that we adults sometimes forget
is that boys volunteer to be scouts
so they can hang out with their friends and go camping.
I mean, that's, you know, basically it
They reduce that whole statement to. I want to have fun.
In order to get at this question,
I'm going to go back
and I'm going to go back.
Let's go all the way back to the founding
of the scout movement and when it started.
So bear with me for a moment.
In the early part of the last century
this new book appears- Scouting for Boys-
And it shows up in the United States
and it just starts to spread like wildfire.
Boys everywhere are getting the book.
They're getting a gang of their buddies together
and they're forming patrols.
They're becoming scouts.
Nobody's telling them that they need to do this.
You know adults aren't out looking for them
and saying: we want you to be scouts.
They just get the book and they're just so energized
by the concept that they decide: I want to be a scout.
So they make up a patrol and eventually the patrols
you know are happening all over the country
And soon there's patrols of scouts
in every neighborhood, in every town
And eventually they decide it would be fun
to go camping with another patrol
and they enlist the help of some adults
and the idea of a scout troop comes about.
And then that scout troop idea: well, we need some help.
So we'll get together with the other troops in town
and you understand where we're going.
In a very short period of time
we end up with a national administrative organization
that's helping these boys do the things that they do.
We go from there to what we have
as the prevailing practice today
Is that a boy, you know, joins a Cub Scout pack
and he spends several years in a Cub Scout pack
and then time comes for him to join a scout troop
And so he transitions up into a scout troop
and somebody puts him in a patrol,
Just like they did when he was in a Cub Scout pack.
you're in this den.
Not a whole lot of choice there. you know,
this is your den,
And so a lot of times that's what we end up with
at the scout troop level.
We just repeat that practice and we say,
well, you're gonna be in such and such patrol,
the new scout patrol, or you're gonna be in this one,
And that patrol may or may not be very important
in the way the troop is administered,
depending on how well the adults in the troop comprehend
and understand the importance of patrols.
Zoom out for a moment and look at our national organization,
And our national organization is a great organization
but it understands things on a very macro level
And from a national standpoint. we know several things.
One of the leading indicators is that we know
scouts stay in scouting longer
If they reach first class rank earlier,
And so the rule of thumb is: we'd love to see them
become first class rank in the first year.
It just gets proven out by surveys and numbers
and things like that.
And we know that older scouts are supposed to be
caring for and leading these younger scouts,
but it doesn't always work in practice
to the satisfaction of adults who are administering troops.
And so you know we hear from adults mostly
and we know that there are some people out there
with promising practices and we look at one
and it's this new scout patrol idea
And that is where we have a group of new boys
and we put them into the troop as a patrol
and they get an older scout who's kind of their troop guide
and then an adult also mentors that patrol
And you know what. it looks great on paper
And it works.
If the troop is administered by adults
and basically led by adults, it works pretty well
And I've gotten really no argument.
Boys have a great experience in troops
that are administered by adults
as well as they have in troops
that are administered by youth.
You know what?
I can't really argue with the results that happen.
I would say I would prefer that our troops
were administered by youth,
because I think that's what scouting actually is.
But let's lay that aside for a moment.
and we know that suggested practices that optimize
the leading indicators are a good thing,
And so we develop and promote this idea
of a new scout patrol.
Let's contrast what happened in the founding of scouting
and what we're doing today. okay,
We've got basically two practices
and the founding years of scouting. boys
are energized and interested in the concept.
They form their own patrols
And present practice is, in most cases,
that decision is kind of an administrative one
on the part of the troop.
So, having gotten the case
and contrasted those two things, I have an opinion.
I amazing, right,
I have an opinion about this.
Well, anybody who's gonna take the time
to stand here with a microphone
and better have an opinion.
I think scouts ought to be the ones
to answer these questions,
just like they did back when scouting
was just beginning to get off the ground.
When new scouts join a troop,
I go to the senior patrol leader
and I ask him what he'll be doing about this.
He knows that they need to go into patrol
and I'll say: how are you gonna do that?
I said, well, he's already in whatever patrol
And I'll say: sounds good to me
and that'll be the end of the discussion.
Nine times out of 10,
a boy joining the troop
who was not in a Weeblos den before
already has a buddy in a patrol somewhere
and that's just gonna work well.
But what about that group of new Weeblos
that are coming into the troop?
Should we put them in a new scout patrol?
Should we call it a new scout patrol?
What do you wanna do?
How do you wanna do it?
Sometimes it works for them just to come in
and be in all in one patrol.
Sometimes they get split up.
It really depends on what they want,
because it's their volunteering to be part of this.
Let them make a choice
and let them change their minds, because they're boys
and they need to change their minds all the time.
What about balancing patrols?
Shouldn't you have? if we have 24 boys in patrols,
we should have patrols of eight guys apiece.
And what about that?
And well, you know what,
From an administrative standpoint
you'd like nice, even patrols, right.
But from a boy standpoint, do they really care?
You know, I would love to see them build a patrol
up to a strength of eight,
but if there's five guys in a patrol
and that's what they like
and that's working for them,
who am I gonna be to come in and say:
we gotta even the numbers up here. okay,
If they've got 10 guys in one patrol
and five guys in another patrol
and three guys in a patrol,
it's not what I would call optimum,
but if it's working, why do I wanna stir the pot?
Why do I wanna mess with that?
Being able to do this presupposes another thing.
It kind of pulls on another thread
and that's youth leadership.
Now, if the youth of the troop,
if the youth in that scout troop,
have actual responsibility to take care of things,
if they're actually leading
and they're not just figureheads,
then they can make these decisions pretty well
If they've been trained to lead
and they've been inculcated with the concept
that they are to care for, support
and be a big brother to younger scouts,
that these are not just little, bothersome little kids
that are just getting in their way
And they have a free hand in making the kinds of decisions
about who's in what patrol and things like that.
I think that the quality of their decisions
will be better than those based on
kind of administrative concerns and things.
Perhaps you would like me to tell you
one way or the other what to do,
but that gives you some food for thought
as you sit and make that decision.
In my book, let the boys choose.
they make better decisions anyway.
That's why they're in the troop in the first place,
because they want to be with their buddies.
If a new group comes in
and it would be useful for them
to have an older scout working with them,
then let the senior patrol leader make that decision right
And monitor and advise and mentor
and do all the things that we always talk about right.
But, Michael, I appreciate the question
and let me know if I can explain it better
or be of any further assistance.
["The Scoutmaster Podcast"].
Hey, thanks for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch with us. okay,
Read the Scoutmaster blog at scoutmastercgcom
And, while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster Podcast on iTunes
and, when you do
And if you have the chance,
feel free to leave a comment or review or a rating.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to do that at stitchercom.
You can leave a shout-out for your fellow leaders,
for your scouts, for your unit
to be broadcast on the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Go to scoutmastercgcom, follow the link to shout-out
and it will give you instructions
on exactly how to do that.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
You can join the nearly 1800 others
who have liked the Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
You can tweet ScoutmasterCG on Twitter
and, for admittance to the ScoutmasterCG circles,
search for ScoutmasterCG on Google+.
And remember, good old fashioned email works too.
You can email me, Clark Green,
with your comments, questions and wild ideas
at ScoutmasterCG at Verizonnet.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster Podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a bit of fun along the way,
and I hope you did.
And before we go, the final word comes from
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.